RFK Jr has just come out and endorsed
some form of reparations for slavery he
said we need federal tax dollars to
quote rebuild black infrastructure like
Banks and businesses he supports quote
direct redress payments or tax credits
uh to black people for by virtue of
being black he says communities that
were specifically targeted for
Destruction need to be specifically
targeted for repair during Jim Crow
black Banks businesses hospitals schools
and Farms were targeted for Destruction
racists knew that without these the
black Community had no chance of
Building Wealth we must set aside
federal dollars to rebuild black
infrastructure you know I hate to say I
told you so I called it I called it when
Americans and when the right-wingers in
particular were saying RFK Jr he's a
right winger that guy he's he's a
Conservative candidate we should back
him over Trump or Dan Santos or somebody
I said he's a lib he's a liberal that's
no knock on him exactly he's always been
a liberal his name's Kennedy he just
sides with us on coid vaccines which is
good but there are other issues